just days ago Kanye West challenged
Adidas to drop him following a week-long
barrage of anti-semitic remarks made on
social media and in National media
appearances
the thing about
Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and they came drop me
say anti-semitic things and Adidas can't
drop me
now what
but Adidas finally broke its silence and
ended the relationship that move will
cost them big but yay even more
immediately knocking him out of the
billionaire ranks yea who had worked
with Adidas since 2013 on his Yeezy line
of super expensive super popular
sneakers thought he was Untouchable
Adidas gets an estimated four to eight
percent of its sales from Yeezy products
according to Investment Bank Cohen
for yay it was an even bigger deal
accounting for 1.5 billion dollars of
his net worth but yay's worth put the
German athletic wear company with its
own Nazi ties dating back to its
Founders in the hot seat What followed
was an even more escalating pressure on
Adidas to sever ties with yay as his
string of anti-semitic remarks Drew
condemnation from the top tiers of
Hollywood for weeks Adidas stayed silent
except to say on October 6 that their
partnership with the a was under review
the pressure mounted on Adidas after an
image was released over the weekend of a
banner draped over a Los Angeles Highway
overpass reading Kanye was right about
the Jews accompanied by a group of white
supremacists giving the Nazi salute to
the drivers below the white supremacists
were apparently referring to yay's
deathcon 3 on Jewish people tweet they
got his Twitter account locked other
anti-semitic remarks got him blocked on
Instagram and thousands of social media
users called on Adidas to drop yay the
company declared in a press release
after a thorough review the company has
taken the decision to terminate the
partnership with yay immediately and
production of Yeezy branded products and
stop all payments to yay and his
companies Adidas will stop the Adidas
easy business with immediate effect with
that gone yay is no longer a billionaire
without Adidas he is worth 400 million
dollars it caps a stunning self-induced
downfall for one of the brashest and
most volatile personalities to have
graced Forbes Pages yay did not respond
to forbes's request for comment the 1.5
billion dollar value of the Adidas deal
was calculated off of multiple annual
earnings based on interviews with
industry experts Forbes had viewed the
royalties he received from Adidas to be
similar to royalties from music catalogs
or film residuals the Adidas income
stream could be sold off those experts
said just like dozens of musicians
including the likes of Bob Dylan and
Bruce Springsteen who have sold off
their life's work over the past two
years the remainder of yay's Fortune
Forbes estimates comes from Real Estate
cash his music catalog and a 5 stake in
ex-wife Kim Kardashian's shapewear firm
skims although a source close to skims
told Forbes that yay hasn't been
involved with the brand since its 2019
launch losing Adidas was the final nail
in yea's net worth coffin Gap terminated
its easy partnership in September
earlier this month JP Morgan reportedly
unbanked him French fashion house
Balenciaga nixed their relationship with
him on October 21st just weeks after he
walked their Runway at Paris fashion
week just yesterday production company
MRC said it would not air a completed
documentary on yay and talent agency CAA
where yay was signed dumped him the two
had been in Partnership since 2013 when
news of their Yeezy collaboration was
announced in the decades since yay has
written wave after wave of conflict with
Taylor Swift with his former recording
home Universal music group and more
recently on social media against Kim
Kardashian and her boyfriend at the time
SNL Alum Pete Davidson now the road has
ended but there's always the chance
relaunch easy on his own just days ago
yay made his first post to parlor the
right-wing social media site he agreed
to acquire for an undisclosed amount
after getting locked out of Twitter and
Instagram
[Music]